ça y est le compte à rebours pour paris
2024 est officiellement lancée les jeux
paralympiques de tokyo se sont refermées
ce dimanche avec la cérémonie de clôture
au stade olympique de la ville la maire
de paris anne hidalgo a reçu le drapeau
paralympique a désormais trois ans des
jeux dans la capitale et la région ile
de france grégory canal est journaliste
pour tv 78 bonsoir vous êtes avec nous
bonsoir lucine et justement c'est
l'occasion de dresser le bilan de cet
événement elle tout d'abord ce chiffre
54 54 médailles ont été glanées par la
délégation française durant les 13 jours
de compétition est dans le détail 11 en
or 14 en argent et 28 en bronze
l'objectif fixé a été pulvérisée
puisqu'il était de 35 médailles au total
est la france termine 14e et a fait bien
mieux que les 28 médailles obtenues à
rio 2016 et dépasse même les 52
médailles de pékin 2008 et parmi elles
les athlètes les plus en lumière le
cycliste alexandre les hôtes et 20 ans
porte drapeau lors de la cérémonie de
clôture pour ses premiers jeux il a
décroché tout de même quatre médailles
dont une en or c'est vrai qu'en est-il
de nosy be no engagés grégory ils ont
brillé justin est justement dans les
épreuves de cyclisme à elle seule qui
ont drainé 28% des médailles tricolores
un nom à retenir celui de marie
patouillet 33 ans natif de versailles et
qui a exercé comme médecin généraliste
dans les yvelines c'est elle qui a
obtenu la première médaille française à
tokyo avec d'abord le bronze en
poursuite individuelle et puis la
cycliste a récidivé une semaine plus
tard avec un nouveau bond sur route pour
la course en ligne à c4 c5 et puis enfin
deux quatrièmes places en contre la
montre et en 500 m contre la montre
également et en natation aussi le
département a brillé il a été au premier
plan oui avec le club saint germanois du
cercle des nageurs de l'ouest 1 qui
avait sa figure de proue pour ces jeux
de tokyo c'est alex portal 19 ans en
lice dans cinq épreuves rien que ça ça
jeunesse et le fait que ce soit comme
marie pas tout il ya une première dans
ces jo ne lui ont pas fait peur médaille
d'argent sur le 200 m 4 nages bronze au
400 m nage libre est 13 4e place au 100
m papillon il paraissait tout de même
déçu au sortir de ces épreuves et ne
cache pas ses ambitions pour paris 2024
deux médailles donc tout comme hugo
didier 19 ans aussi originaire des
yvelines les natif du chesnay est
licencié désormais dans un club de
haute-garonne l'argent ou 400 m nage
libre s 9 et le bronze au 200 m quatre 4
nages sm 9
présent avec deux sportifs qui ont été
sociétaire de club yvelinois par le
passé timothée adolphe 31 ans né à
versailles qui a habité à guyancourt il
a débuté l'athlétisme
cinquième à rio disqualifié pour ces
jeux de tokyo en séries du 400 m il a
pris sa revanche sur le 100 m -t 11 une
première médaille en argent de l'année
aux côtés de son guide bruno n a pris 6
et peut-être c'est l'une des grandes
déceptions de ces jeux paralympiques
nantenin keita 36 ans ex licenciés de la
sky s'est lentement l'entente athlétique
de saint quentin en yvelines elle a
signé son meilleur temps ce de la saison
sur le 400 m haies 13 mais ce n'a pas
été suffisant pour obtenir une médaille
la tenant du titre en or à rio 2016
termine au pied du podium à la quatrième
place et on termine ce tour d'horizon
par les sports de raquette deux
premières également décidément c'était
une grande première pour de nombreuses
yvelinois sur ces jeux de tokyo est déjà
en para badminton alors s'il faut noter
justin c'est que c'était une première
pour le para badminton l entrée est
cette discipline comme sport
paralympique cette année le numéro cinq
mondial merrill loket 23 ans et arrêtée
dès la phase de groupes une victoire
contre le polonais aime rose avant de
céder par deux fois contre les
indonésiens henry muttsee et annule gros
qui obtiendront plus tard respectivement
la médaille d'argent et la médaille de
bronze donc c'était aussi à des gros qui
a affronté l'yvelinois et enfin en
tennis fauteuil également charlotte
faire banques inquiète dans le top 40
mondial qui s'entraînent à voisins le
bretonneux elles étaient engagés en
simple et en double deux défaites au
premier tour face à l'américaine
mathewson en simple 1 6 0 6 3 et en
double avec sa compatriote emmanuel
morges contre la doublette du comité
paralympique russe avotvaz abuse nova en
trois sets 6-2 5-7 2-6